distinguished guests members of the
jewish community
earlier this month i joined president
macron in the ponteon in paris
to honor two founding figures of the
european union
germany
and simon vale
when simon vale was just 16 she was
arrested
and sent to auschwitz
because she was jewish
she survived auschwitz
and then in the winter of 1945
she was sent on a death march to
bergen-belsen
concentration camp
again
she survived
after the war she dedicated her life to
public service in france
and to building a more just and humane
world
she cared deeply for human rights and
the rights of women
simon vale became the first president of
the european parliament
and having witnessed europe's darkest
hour
she helped build our future
as a founding mother of the european
union
today
we remember all those
who survived
and the millions who perished in the
holocaust
anti-semitism dehumanizes
the jewish people
it strips individuals of their rights
and dignity
in nazi germany
the dehumanization
opened the door to the showa
we must never forget
to remember
is to make a stand to defend
human dignity
everywhere
so today we also look to the future
after the war
europe was built upon the promise of
peace
of putting an end to hatred and
ignorance
but anti-semitism is again on the rise
it threatens jewish communities in
europe
and this is why i presented the
commission's first ever strategy on
combating anti-semitism and fostering
jewish life in europe
because jewish life is an integral part
of europe's history
and of europe's future
and this is what simon vale fought for
the uncompromising defense of human
dignity reason and moderation
i still remember how powerful speech to
the german bundestag on a holocaust
remembrance day
almost 20 years ago
an entire country paused
to listen
to her words
she made us face the crimes
the horror
and the death of humanity
a past that would never get past her
she called on future generations to keep
the memory alive
as she said
basketball
end of quote
if we protect the facts we can break the
cycle of hatred and violence
europe will remain united in diversity
faithful to the values of its founding
fathers and mothers
you can always count
on the european commission to stand by
your side